good morning Hank it's Tuesday November
11th Armistice Day also Veterans Day
here in the US happy Veterans Day also
it's Kurt Vonnegut's birthday I'm a
little bit sick to them rocking the
husky voice let's go talk to Andrew and
Laci it's quite resumed its questioning
its question louder but not it's
question lam with control issues it's
question Tuesday and we're answering
real questions from real nerdfighters
nicely don't you what's your favorite
scene in the movie or the book bathtub
Oh with Q with Q drunk Ben by the way
this is Josh and Claire I'm so mad at
coy dad not dead dad this is just
Jessica Claire Foster
they're playing Lacey and Andrew in the
movie two roles that have bigger roles
in the movie I think than in the book
yes is John a good executive producer
yeah he has so much mr. Graham's grief
does John actually do anything on set a
related question yes great um great
answer Dana asks how do I ask out this
guy I like to get coffee with me I'm
gonna handle this one because I have the
husky voice so I think I'm qualified
sexy hey hey Dana's friend hey hey how's
it going you want to get coffee what is
your favorite prop on the movie set that
is not a difficult question five Santa's
black Santa's I like the beer sword
little accents
your son was very specifically the
animatronic black Xander that just waved
at us all day what's your favorite song
I like banana pancakes by Jack Johnson
that's a good one
can I do a favorite band instead yes
Yeah right now my favorite band right
now and no party kids reenact your
favorite emoji I'm a monkey who among
the boys in the movie in your opinion
can do the most pushups Boston one doing
push-ups are talking takes the first
shot I mean I think if that could do for
penguins or polar bears hang polar bears
giraffes are Lions giraffes whoa lions
why did I say that
zombies are unicorns don't eat your corn
do you see net as a friend a brother or
a lover you can only pick one
which is good I only want to pick one
lover for sure over the best lover
no um for me he is a friend he's a great
friend not a really great friend
musically nobody sees nowt as a brother
or a lover do you have a favorite book
Heyford paper town happy Thank You
halston
paper downtown good work guys favorite
Beatle Oh John Lennon jazz favorite
Beatle John Lennon favorite color we're
boy my favorites are also John and green
oh I see why they're so high poppies all
I see why do you have a ritual before
you start filming a scene yes I say all
my life since back I mean when we do you
really we all sometimes when we have a
big group saying we will scene we will
sing together do you have advice for the
heartbroken I think you know just
surround yourself with your friends and
family and um just remember that you can
love again I would say use it oh that's
good too yeah they like do something
with it don't just like wait for the
pain to go away kind of embrace it like
write or paint or draw or sing or cry
but I think that the best advice
especially for an emotion that intense
is to use the emotion because things
like that are rare and they feel bad but
they are not
thank you guys for being part of
question Tuesday Hank happy pizza missed
the only time of the year when you can
get my face on an astonishing variety of
items and I will see you tomorrow bye
Hank
let's go talk to Angela talk so bad it
pointing and just gonna do it with a
gesture